no one wants to talk about it especially
on the right but there is 100 percent a
racial caste system that currently
exists in this country I mean this woman
was villainized she was called a burglar
every name in the book right because
she's the caricature of a Karen which is
a slur for white women who dare to you
know complain about the degeneracy that
they see in their communities
um that that just you know say I don't
want it to be this way and I think they
tried to Daniel Penny her they really
did they tried to throw her under the
bus she was fired from her job or I
think placed on yeah placed on leave
from her job
um and the media came after her and you
know who was in docs the people who
attacked her I mean it's just totally
backwards the media is out there
defending criminals Lawless gangs just
that are running the streets and I think
our law enforcement too you're seeing
selective enforcement here right you
have people that are allowed to behave
in a criminal Manner and then you have
people who aren't